[Musique]
il était à côté de la reine
ils ne le sont plus au musée de cire
madame tussauds de londres le couple
royal a déjà été déplacé dans la section
internationale
[Musique]
le musée de cire a déjà donné le ton en
tout cas selon la bbc la duchesse au
sexe a déjà plié bagage et serait allé
rejoindre son fils de huit mois au
canada
pendant ce temps une réunion de crise a
lieu au palais à londres pour trouver
une solution
le prince harry devra faire face seule à
la colère des windsor
car l'annoncé de leur retrait partiel de
la vie royale sans en informer la reine
a eu l'effet d'une bombe
le prince aurait-il défier l'autorité de
sa grand mère
shocking diront certains le couple est
en train de faire trembler les murs de
buckingham
une fois c'est tout un choc dit il et
c'est irrespectueux envers la reine à
trafic
c'est megan qui décide et je me sens mal
pour harry nous voulons qu'il revienne
la nouvelle est tel qu'elle a éclipsé le
vrai break site
les députés britanniques ont voté
aujourd'hui en faveur de la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne mais
rien à faire c'est la saga royal qui
retient l'attention
on évoque la complicité de la reine avec
le prince mais depuis le mariage la
pression médiatique était trop forte
pour le couple aujourd'hui les journaux
se défendent
ça fait partie du jeu dit le rédacteur
en chef du daily mail 9 heures
ne jamais se plaindre ne jamais
s'expliquer c'est la devise de la
monarchie itil et faire de son mieux
pour avoir une bonne relation avec la
presse
mais beaucoup de questions restent en
suspens vont ils conserver leur titre
d'altesse royale qui leur confère entre
autres des voyages gratuits
la sécurité au canada l'histoire fait
sourire tim hortons promet d'offrir des
cafés gratuits aux couples et selon le
national post soixante pour cent des
canadiens voudraient que le prince harry
devienne gouverneur général en tout cas
une question demeure le couple va-t-il
rester ou non dans la monarchie
à 93 ans la reine fait face selon
certains aux caprices de son petit fils
elle qui a voué sa vie à l'institution
sans dire un mot ici asa bolger guise
radio canada
[Applaudissements]